[Musique]
ce lundi 19 décembre le département de
La Réunion a signé deux conventions de
partenariat avec l'Afrique du Sud et le
Mozambique pour la diffusion et la
valorisation du patrimoine
iconographique de l'océan Indien auprès
des populations travaillées de concert
pour enrichir les connaissances sur une
histoire commune celle de l'esclavage
voilà tout l'enjeu de ses conventions
en ma qualité de président du
Département de la réunion je suis bien
évidemment heureux d'avoir signé cette
convention ces deux conventions avec nos
amis sud-africains comme avec nos amis
mozambica tout simplement parce que nous
avons à échanger sur des bases
historiques des archives aussi bien ici
au département de La Réunion comme aux
ambigo en Afrique du Sud il y a des
données immenses qu'il ne convient de
consulter pour enrichir nos
connaissances ou à nous permettre de
nous ouvrir au monde et c'est pour cela
que nous avons signé ces convention qui
nous engage justement à mettre à
disposition dans les archives des trois
pays bien évidemment Afrique du Sud
Mozambique et Réunion et à partir de ces
bases d'archives de permettre à nos
chercheurs d'approfondir cette période
trouble de notre histoire la
connaissance que nous avons de ces pays
troupes de notre histoire que
l'esclavage et aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans cet élan de recherche de façon à
rendre à tout un chacun et bien
l'histoire qui est la sienne à rendre à
nos concitoyens réunionnais
la connaissance de ce qui a été
l'esclavage ici à la réunion nous nous
disons aussi que les libertés ne sont
jamais acquises nous devons travailler à
consolider cette société réunionnaise du
bien vivre ensemble à nous ouvrir pour
renforcer les libertés individuelles et
collectives c'est cela le sens de ces
conventions que nous avons signé ce
matin également présent lors de cette
signature l'ancien Premier ministre et
président de la Fondation pour la
mémoire de l'esclavage Jean-Marc Ayrault
a salué la qualité du travail engagé par
le Département très souvent beaucoup de
gens ignorent que l'océan Indien est
concerné par la traitement que cette
histoire terrible cette histoire qui
laisse des traces encore et qu'il faut
non pas oublier mais comment dire
surmonter pour un vivre ensemble
nécessaire et de ce point de vue la
Réunion est un exemple extraordinaire
parce qu'il y a une diversité de
population d'origine dont certaines sont
venues par la sensation de l'esclavage
d'autres par langagisme d'autres encore
pour rien d'autre raison migratoires
mais qui sont une référence pour tous
les autres Français parce que ici malgré
les problèmes existent il y en a par
exemple et il faut les surmonter les
traiter il y a une volonté de vivre
ensemble et de partager en l'essentiel
c'est heureux que ce travail se poursuit
c'est un travail de grande grande
qualité de grande exigences avec les
outils dont dispose le département
notamment les archives départementales
mais en même temps avec un objectif
c'est de faire partager à toute la
population pas de réserver à aux experts
aux initiés ou ceux qui sont plus forts
plus informés ou plus
dans les livres non il faut en faire une
affaire populaire ce partenariat
permettra le partage des collections sur
l'esclavage conserver au sein de
l’iconautech historique de l'océan
Indien du musée de Villèle du slave
Lodge Museum en Afrique du Sud et des
archives historique du Mozambique
[Musique]